après la corruption l'insécurité est ce
qui a suscité l'immense ras-le-bol des
brésiliens 68000 homicides l'an dernier
un record des meurtres un peu partout
mais surtout dans les favelas c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont voté jaillir ball sauna au
delà les favelas ce président de lo ng
viva rio a passé sa vie à s'en occuper
de quoi désespérer mais non rien layton
dans cette élection
le monsieur le président parlant langage
très direct langage que je dirais un
poney c'est populaire c'est papa poule
et un militaire c'est inquiétant mais
alors si toi ces intérêts étaient ainsi
atteinte à la situation antérieure ou
même actuelle c'est ça des opérations de
police contre des bandes de petits
criminels de narcotrafiquants mais
c'était trop cette année le gouvernement
fédéral a envoyé l'armée dans les
favelas des armes sont saisis beaucoup
de drogue aussi
mais il ya des morts des criminels mais
aussi des citoyens pris dans des
fusillades 14 morts ici dans un
affrontement à niteroi en banlieue de
rio où la violence est très grand dit
elle il ya des morts toutes les heures
toutes les heures quelqu'un meurt et les
familles pl des militaires aussi sont
tués ici de au cours d'opérations dans
les favelas le comble a été l'assassinât
d'une conseillère municipale militants
issus des favelas marielle frango qui a
révolté le brésil tout entier
je crois qu'il ya une situation de
guerre c'est pas une guerre
traditionnelle évidemment robin césar
fernandes propose une stratégie inspirée
des nations unies
il faut imposer la paix peace en force
mais il faut faire la paix sabeg demande
une participation des institutions de la
communauté le faut maintenir la paix
puisque ep 3 dimensions rien de ça dans
ce que propose jaillir bars saunas ou la
passe cette illusion tout simplement
dire il fallait pousser comme ça alors
ça c'est facile à dire
on a ça déjà en dessus tout les pains
aux toilettes jaillir bolson araud a dit
qu'il voulait armer les gens donner le
droit de tirer à vue sur les délinquants
ait abaissé l'âge de la responsabilité
de 18 à 16 ans ce qu'on redoute c'est
qu'il donne ainsi carte blanche à une
chasse aux petits délinquants de la part
des milices jean michel leprince
radio-canada rio janeiro